خرافات الحاضر 67 كانت خرافه
تراها
197 نعم في عام 67 كانت القصه الرئيسيه
التي ترويها اسرائيل هي انه كان عليها خوض
الحرب عام 67 لماذا لان جمال عبد الناصر
كان يؤسس تحالفا يهدف الى تدمير اسرائيل
نحن نعلم الان من الوثائق ان اسرائيل خططت
لحرب
وذلك سابقا في عام
1963 لماذا بسبب الاتفاق الذي ابرمت مع
الاردن عام 48 لم يكتمل انشاء اسرائيل
كانت الضفه الغربيه في عيد الاردنيين وكان
قطاع غزه في عيد المصريين لقد احتاجوا الى
الحرب لانشاء اسرائيل التي ارادو والتي
تضم جميع تلك المدن المهمه بالنسبه لهم
نابلس والخليل وشرقي القدس اعتقد انه فيما
يتعلق بقطاع غزه فانهم لم يكونوا متاكدين
تماما من انهم راغبون به ام لا لكنهم في
النهايه قرروا الاستيلاء عليه نعم ان بعض
الحركات وانا شخص صادق جدا ولا اخفي او
ازيف الحقيقه في انتقادات للزعماء العرب
وما الى ذلك انا لا اقوم بانتقاد اسرائيل
فقط انا شخص اميل الى النقد لقد ساعدت بعض
الاجراءات التي اتخذها جمال عبد الناصر
الاسرائيليين على اتنام الفرصه التاريخيه
لانشاء اسرائيل العظمى هذه للبطولات
ال الاسف يعني الفارغه لقد كان واثقا بشكل
كبير في السلطه التابعه له على الرغم من
انني اعتقد انه كان يامل وفقا الاعتقاد في
ان تؤدي افعاله الى تدخل المجتمع الدولي
لكنه انجرف على ما اعتقد قليلا في الخطاب
وما الى ذلك لكن الشيء الاكثر اهميه هو ان
اسرائيل كانت ستختلط هذه الحرب عاجلا ام
اجلا لان معظم الجنرالات الاسرائيليين عام
48 مع القاده الاسرائيليين عام 77
اشاروا بالقول انه في الاعوام ما بين 48
و67 كان خطا فادحا السماح للاردن
بالاحتفاظ بالضفه الغربيه سيتعين علينا ان
ننتهز اي فرصه لانتزاع الضفه الغربيه من
الاردن وضمها الى
اسرائيل